un grand débat de la pêche aujourd'hui
et demain à l'institut martiniquais des
sports au lamentin débat avec le comité
régional des pêches bonjour olivier
marie reine
bonjour bonjour aux auditeurs vous êtes
le président de ce comité régional des
pêches lorsqu'on regarde le programme de
ces deux jours de discussions on a
l'impression que tout est déjà orchestré
une demi douzaine de thèmes
l'aquaculture des fonds européens les
jeunes les aides de la 7e le
développement de la filière la gestion
de la ressource
finalement il y aura très peu de place
pour la spontanéité des marins pêcheurs
un peu moins de milliers de mal de
marins or les curés pourtant tellement
de choses à dire ollier marie reine
alors faut vraiment un fil conducteur
mais la parole de nos pêcheurs c'est
surtout ça l'esprit du débat celle
ordonnée tendre le micro pêcheurs on
attend des propositions 2 dont on
souhaite un débat constructif
justement la réalité de la pêche
martinique c'est quoi c'est simple je
vais pas déconnecté de la pêche
l'aquaculture
aujourd'hui deux fermes agricoles qui
produisent aujourd'hui moins d'un peu
plus de 20 tonnes il ya dix ans nous
étions à peu près à 100 tonnes de canne
de guillon c'est un peu moins de 800
entreprises de pêche patron pêcheur et
moins 250 salariés 700 bateaux
immatriculés martin car je pourrais way
90% pour la petite pêche côtière alors
la vraie réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
nous faisons une pêche durable
donc il ya pas de pêche industrielle
amazon hic est que c'est un homme un
poisson donc on est dans l'air du temps
moi je dure à pêche de proximité très
peu on prélève très très peu dans notre
environnement respecte la hausse
ouais mais est-ce qu'on peut pas parler
de pêche de survie lorsqu'on connaît le
groupe d'âge de nos marins pêcheurs ça
change ça change et on a quand même pas
mal de demain un pêcheur qui partent à
la retraite qui a qui arrêtent et
puisqu'il ya aussi des difficultés
vous avez une réglementation qui se dit
aussi et puis certains nous disent bon
j'arrête ça devient trop complexes ou
moi bon il arrête mais c'est un effet
social ni très néfaste 1 mais vous avez
aussi quelques jeunes très peu de jeu 90
de la profession
on a moins de dix installations par
année donc si vous laissez là le la
difficulté est parmi ces marins pêcheurs
qui parmi les seniors parmi les aînés de
7 cette profession il y en a quand même
qui sont obligés d'aller sur nous parce
qu'ils doivent
subsister doivent survivre alors oui
parce qu'il faut faire des compléments
de retraite
anciennement ils avaient ils cotisent à
une demi retraite que ce qu'on appelle
deux miroirs donc beaucoup de nos
collègues ont 400 500 euros de retraite
aujourd'hui ils font en complément
d'activité de salir rouler en continuant
leur maîtrise des fois des âges à
s'élever à 80 ans 70 ans n'est pas parce
qu'ils ont à 100% vie c'est parce que
l'on fait en complément et ce sont des
gens dignes qui vont très peu dans les
tic sociaux pour diot j'ai besoin donc
ils vont travailler mais la difficulté
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ces gens là ne
peuvent de moins en moins se le faire
parce qu'on leur a supprimé leur espace
de travail exhorte le chlordécone est au
centre du débat de la pêche toujours y
revenir on vais revenir mais où finit de
nous olivier marienne un homme une pêche
aux poissons
comment peut-on vivre avec ça alors
quand je vous dirais même une pêche je
parle de pêche du rabbin quand les
marins pêcheurs auparavant mais
arriveront sur les dcp aujourd'hui 80% à
85% des débats ont commencé des poissons
pélagiques qui sont pêchés autour de
dbcp malin 2006 à son futur de poissons
oui merci j'ai envie de vous dire que
bon les pêcheurs lyon on a l'habitude
bien c'est pas un métier facile c'est
difficile quand ya pas de dcp quand le
yen à pâques on a une stratégie de
développement martinez qui depuis
dissipée normalement doit être public et
vous tous les pêcheurs doivent avoir
accès à des dcp aujourd'hui on peut pas
en mettre
il ya des difficultés y en a pas si vous
voulez l'action publique n'a pu n'a pas
pu remettre les marins pêcheurs se sont
organisés pour m et ça crée des
divisions autour de la profession quand
vous avez vous investi vous n'êtes pas
content de moi qui viennent suivre des
cpg presti donc ça crée énormément de
problèmes mais j'ai envie de vous dire
que avec ça on peut vivre quand même
rien d'aider ces pays a de la ressource
on peut vivre ouais quand on doit tirer
un peu de trésorerie notre poche qui est
déjà assez tendu m des dcp
si vous voulez le niveau y descend
aujourd'hui à chef d'entreprise à la
pêche on essaie de faire le smic mais
avec dignité
je n'ai imaginé un chef d'entreprise qui
essaient de faire le smic j'ai beaucoup
de mal à comprendre que la profession ne
soit pas plus organisés que cela alors
on a essayé de l'organiser mais
n'oublions pas que
un strap je sais que ça a été tragique
pour la profession le chlordécone
on a mal évalué les effets néfastes de
cour d'école de nos professions ben
écoute et sociales au niveau social
c'est un effet de structure vous
imaginez que 33% des côtes du journaux
mais on a dû aux pêcheurs vous pouvez
pas pêcher la faune fait un report
violeur large sans estimer que le
européens sur leur large a eu 10 k o a
des conséquences sur le long terme pour
le modèle économique votre vie pêcher
dans un territoire bien concerné et en
vous dès demain matin vous fait trente
kilomètres en bus
oui mais on a mal évalué ça aujourd'hui
on se rend compte que ya une difficulté
à ce niveau là et ça a eu un effet d
structurant pour la profession on a peur
d'une coopérative force que les niveaux
de production à des sens est descendu le
niveau de trésorerie des entreprises est
descendue mais tout est descendu aussi
corps vous avez dit un peu plus autour
de 800 marins pêcheurs 90% de la
profession qui s'adonnent à la pêche
côtière à la pêche du haut niveau du
littoral
vous l'avez évoqué également season
chlore déconner ces zones protégées
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va dire aux jeunes
pour qu'ils puissent revenir dans ce
métier si vous entrez dans cette
profession il faudra vous faire à l'idée
qu'il faudra les deux péchés de plus en
plus loin alors j'avais de plus en plus
loin il faut être organisé il faut
d'abord aujourd'hui on a ciblé quelque
chose qui nous permet de nous faire
vivre c'est la pêche pcp d'accord dans
les chiffres sont là bon on peut pas les
démentir
avec 80 85 tout est limité il ya des
règlements qui sont là mais aujourd'hui
et je besoin ils ont un atout ils sont
forts mais on ne devient pas pêcheur
comme ça sur mes clefs d'augmenter
quand vous êtes pêcheurs aujourd'hui
quand ils arrivent aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont prêts à s'installer
ils ont inclus au niveau formation
donc c'est un atout si toutefois il ya
une difficulté ils peuvent avoir accès à
des infos maritime un petit peu
différent de la pêche gens qu'ils ont si
vous voulez des atouts aujourd'hui oui
ils peuvent diversifier leurs activités
j'ai démarré il ya trop de barrez
pêcheurs qu'il faut du tourisme par
exemple au lieu peut-être de le pêcher
le poisson
je pense que dans certaines zones
on leur interdit l'accès au territoire
notamment dans la zone atlantique où les
fonds de belfort le fasse
bah écoute et on leur a dit du jour et
barbiche et la sni 26 vous gâter capuche
et fallait bien trouver une astuce pour
continuer à vivre parce que les gens qui
font les interdictions ils ont leur
salaire tous les mois
donc il a fallu que la profession se
prennent en charge certains sont des
médias du tourisme on va faire un
complément d'activité à l'activité pêche
et je les en quoi je pense que
finalement qu'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est également un pêcheur vivre
dignement de son activité
parce que monsieur mâcon il n'a pas
donné nous il n'a pas trouvé la relation
entre claude économique ans les
différents concerts il n'y met en doute
mis un noah n'y a pas de doute c'est
lorsqu'on fait des prélèvements dans des
zones où il ya du chlordécone
le prochain cours des conseils à niveau
de chlordécone dans les boissons ça on
peut pas m c'est le seul endroit on peut
pas y a pas de flou à ce niveau là alors
l'effet néfaste
aujourd'hui mais on subit toujours le
chlordécone
lorsque je me promène ou voeckler quand
je vais au carbet quand je vais ailleurs
où on peut faire de la pêche
quelle garantie g que le poisson qui
m'est proposée par des marins pêcheurs
de martinique a été pêché dans une zone
cède à leur procès partie de notre
projet baisse adage sa charge zone ce
qui importe c'est d'identifier la rose
racheter les boissons il ya beaucoup de
cirque informelle mais achetez votre
poisson là où vous êtes sûr de connaître
le mans un pêcheur et c'est là que je
dis et rich
alors pour vous assurer les marins
pêcheurs sont des gens très
consciencieux on connaît les limites en
séoul dans les endroits il faut pêcher
ne pas pêcher or si les autres pêcheurs
ne pas pêcher ils sont comme vous et moi
je leur lot d'une soeur d'amélie pour se
montrer vraiment répondu aux dons qu'il
parlait intoxiqué la population nous
proche du mono n'est en réalité sociale
ou intégrée de ces moulins les gars ils
vont pêcher au large la plus âpre font
et ce qu'ils font là les nas le filet il
applique avec l'augmentation ils vont
pas dans des endroits pollués
il parlait pas les trous nous café la
qualité ça veut dire quand je dis à nos
cafés attention chanuc à faire et nous
former vous ça parce que panama empêcher
qu'ils allaient l'emmener jeudi à kippa
sans qu'ils aient pas connaître
réglementation au niveau pour des
collants qui zonent poil et qu'ils ont
une peau pâle
alors l'avenir la partie fixe et la
france sa force qui est dans l'europe
avec bruxelles qui permettra à paris
de financer le renouvellement de la
flottille de navires de pêche corps ne
sont pas considérés comme étant une
menace pour l'environnement dans la
préservation de l'espèce que veut la
martinique sur ce dossier que veulent
les marais pêcheurs et vous déjà fait
des remontées par exemple au préfet de
région
alors à l'occasion du grand débat on va
lui faire remonter un certain nombre de
propositions qui viennent qui sont issus
des paiements un pêcheur s'est enfin il
ya une large concertation là d'autres
plats filière si vous voulez alors il ya
une tentative de l'état de para la dm2
offert un projet lui-même servir des
fonctionnaires qui sont autour de la
table veulent nous prendre un petit
projet qu'on a nous à qui on a donné un
avis défavorable le haut aujourd'hui a
dit à l'état membre banco je vous
autorise à donner des fonds publics à la
filière pour le renouvellement de de
toutes les installer pour la flotte
bateaux neufs mais l'europe n'a pas dit
qui finance un indice autorise à l'état
c'est à dire avoir des fonds publics ça
peut être la collectivité ça peut te
l'état ok mais c'est une annonce qu'on a
eu depuis le comme schéma qu'on avait
été en guyenne mais après ça on a
énormément de petites tentatives de sous
chef de service de politiques qui
viennent
ils ont entendu quelque chose qu'un
viaduc là on veut nous faire suivre bien
espèce de dictature nous dire bon voici
le modèle économique mais nous quand on
analyse le modèle économique proposé par
l'état c'est un modèle économique qui
existaient déjà et qui a fait faillite
partout on a des enfants parler de notre
mission on peut monter démonter et
réparer que c'est l'échec ce qu'ils nous
proposent aujourd'hui les marins
pêcheurs aucun quand même pas mal
d'expérience si ça comment ils vont y
lequel elle a besoin thème de
renouvellement de flotte
donc il faut les écouter et ce sera
l'occasion de le faire justement
l'occasion de ces deux jours du grand
débat de la pêche à l'institut
martiniquais des sports bercy olivier
barry lane président du comité régional
des pêches d'avant était ce matin avec
nous dans son caddie bonne journée
[Musique]